as i was speaking i have received word
chris are you ready for this do we have
breaking news
let me tell you as your overall
impersonation skill goes that wasn't bad
oh thank you
antonio brown will be back at the
raiders facility today wow so there's
our answer how about that how about that
we we we
we need to do that with more subjects we
start talking about something and
somebody texts me the answer but i am
told reliably that brown will be back at
the raiders facility
today so when he walks back in the door
chris what happens um
nothing i don't think anything's gonna
happen they're just gonna be happy he's
there it'll be all smiles they're gonna
embrace him uh the nfl
is a business and uh just like any
business you know superstars or the
people who are at the top of their
business they get treated differently
and that is no different in the nfl and
that's with all 32 teams now it's a
little too of a lesser extent in new
england as compared to the other 31 but
guys in the locker room they're going to
be happy he's back hey the guys in the
locker room want to win because if they
they know antonio brown helps them win
and if they win that means there's pro
possibly more money for them in the
future whether that's staying with the
raiders or being a free agent because we
know teams that go to the playoffs or go
to the super bowl when you're a free
agent on those team there's a little
uptick in what you get money wise
because you know you played well the
team played well and all that just kind
of goes in the right direction you know
resentment in the locker room there'll
be a few guys but they're not going to
let it be known because they're going to
know what kind of a power player he is
how important he is to the organization
the head coach loves them and the guys
that resent them are gonna be the guys
that are wanting more money or on the
last year of a contract and they go damn
this guy acting a fool and he's getting
30 million guaranteed and i'm being you
know johnny organization over here and
doing everything right and nobody even
talked to my agent so that's only only
spot i see resentment coming from
yeah and look the bottom line is as we
were speculating on where he is what's
going on the reports that he had gone
radio silent the fact that he is going
to be back with the team today is
progress it's a step in the right
direction the question is when will he
be healthy enough to practice when will
he be ready to play and this helmet
issue is still percolating and let's be
clear on this because i got to give
credit to the reader that pointed this
out to me yesterday the idea that the
shut air advantage the preferred helmet
model for antonio brown has not been
affirmatively banned by the nfl i think
in part because it's been discontinued
since 2011 they probably didn't feel
compelled to try to test it to determine
whether or not it should be banned so
it's not banned so the noc-sae executive
director and general counsel michael
oliver confirmed yesterday to this
reader and then michael oliver told me
if you can find the shut air advantage
that is less than 10 years old it can be
recertified the nfl i'm told has
informed antonio brown that that
approach would work so now
antonio brown and his representatives
looking for a shut air advantage that is
less than 10 years old so yeah i got it
it's amazing how this stuff happens but
it's happened and uh he may be back
playing soon and he may be wearing a
shut air advantage that he buys off of
somebody in topeka kansas on ebay the
does does the reader have a name or are
we just going to continue to refer to
him as reader i gotta i gotta i gotta
look at i'm i'm sorry a lot happened
yesterday i mean damn he only did all
this traffic on the website and you
can't even remember his damn name some
nice guy you are i think it's tim oh
little tim reader good nice and nice to
have you but seriously that was amazing
work by uh i guess tim we're gonna call
him now
uh uh am i crazy to think that like
every kid that's out of high school or
out of college football who saved their
helmet
right now and has a shut helmet is going
home going to go wait was mine made
after 2011 i mean i think that's what's
gonna happen i don't think he's going to
find one on ebay i think someone's going
to find it for him and they're going to
get in contact with him through social
media and they're going to end up
sending it it's going to be this big
story and antonio brown's going to give
him tickets and a jersey and all that
i'm just i'm calling my shot right now
right there you're like
amy trask the former raiders president
pointed out last night on twitter as
this story was was percolating wouldn't
this be a great opportunity for shut
to dig into their warehouses somewhere
right and find one of these right and
and fly to oakland or alameda wherever
they are right now napa valley wherever
they're having their their training camp
and hand him this thing and make a big
deal about it great marketing for shut
because even though they don't make the
air advantage they still make helmets
and chris it was funny when i was
walking up here to the studio today
there's a cabinet down in in our garage
where my kids old football helmets are
sitting up on top i made sure that
neither one of those was a sh air
advantage and they aren't but i i think
everybody's gonna be looking for a
shut-air advantage less than 10 years
old and i think antonio you're right
he's not going to have to look hard to
find one because one way or another
somebody is going to hand him one on a
platter that is going to be less than 10
years old it's going to be able to be
certified and and once they paint it up
with the raiders kellers that's what
he's going to be wearing this year uh
yeah it's it's
this is amazing i mean it just really is
there's two days in a row we're talking
about this story or i mean it's five
days in a row i mean this has been going
on forever now it's just uh
you couldn't make it up but i am glad
that antonio brown's back in in the
building are going to be back today i
mean again i'm john gruden i spent a lot
of time with him i want him to be
successful out there i want to watch
antonio brown you know go out there and
carve people up with derek carr i mean
hey football's fun when antonio brown's
act there out there you know making
plays and doing
end zone dances and all of that so it's
good that he's finally back and and
hopefully he can practice here real soon
and if he's back and he's 100 at some
point i mean what does that really do
for the offense i i think the jury's
still out on the whole chicken and the
egg roethlisberger antonio brown can
antonio brown thrive without
roethlisberger there to fit the ball
into those tight windows we take that
part of it for granted yeah
is derek carr going to be delivering the
ball accurately or is antonio brown
going to have to stretch out expose
himself to a big hit is he gonna get
frustrated if the balls aren't accurate
now we can get back to the old questions
we were obsessing over whether or not
this offense can truly take advantage of
an antonio brown i i think they can i
don't think it's going to be
maybe as sexy always as it was with ben
roethlisberger with you know big bombs
down the field and everything like that
because big ben is special that way he's
one of the greatest deep ball throwers
i've ever seen
but i think within within the offense
and john gruden's you know
magic show and illusions and everything
they'll manipulate more plays for
antonio brown maybe they did in
pittsburgh you know pittsburgh i think
they called a lot of times they just
called plays and wherever the ball went
it went or if big ben saw a match up he
liked okay i'm going to go to antonio
because i know he's going to beat this
guy man to man and certainly they called
some place for him but my experience in
the john gruden offense is he's going to
make it all about antonio brown he's
going to get all the cheap catches all
the short ones all the screens all that
he's gonna force a defense to play their
hand to stop him and then therefore it's
going to open up guys like maybe a j.j
nelson uh or tyrell williams or other
receivers on the list that's how i kind
of envision it all coming and coming
about
hey the x factor and all this too chris
first round draft pick josh jacobs the
running back for alabama if you are
obsessed with taking away antonio brown
good luck having an an eighth man
available in the box to slow down josh
jacobs and the better jacobs performs
then you have to start tilting in his
direction antonio brown may get
favorable match up so i think josh
jacobs is going to be really the wild
card in weathering to what extent no
doubt this works for antonio brown in
oakland
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports